open 19 vaccine policies change for
students at nevada colleges students
will no longer be required to get the
covid19 vaccine well the legislative
commission voted not to continue the
emergency vaccine regulation approved
back in august kate houston explains
in a split 66 vote legislator struck
down the vaccine mandate on nevada
campuses this includes unlv unr and csn
i'm not very favorable of mandates but i
did have to make the decision
a decision to where i did feel a bit
forced
into and pressured into this vote comes
more than a month after students like
isaac hernandez were required to get the
vaccine to enroll in spring term i'm
thinking in my in my head i guess that i
should have never gotten the vaccine
hernandez says the inconsistency is
confusing for students to install a
mandate and then overwrite it months
after the deadline was already due it's
so inconsistent i know for a fact a lot
of students are outraged at the moment
although the legislative commission did
not support the early approval of the
mandate the state plans to present the
regulations again governor sisilak says
the rollback is disappointing given
what's going on across the country we
had another thousand cases in nevada
today
that's the second day in a row that
we've had a thousand or more cases and
it's obviously on the upswing we need to
do everything we can to control this
omnicron and hopefully not have another
huge surge like other states are
experiencing the nevada system of higher
education says any students whose
registration has been on hold for not
having the vaccine will be lifted
immediately kate houston live local now
the vote also struck down a mandate for
state workers who interact with
vulnerable populations employees at
nevada colleges are still required to
have the vaccines and masks are also
required indoors